après des années d'efforts il est devenu
le plus noble des parisiens à
l'inspiration qu'elle s'en va la france
je dirais principalement nous mêmes
jusqu'au jour où il a connu son confrère
charges qui a une antenne aux piétons
une grosse rechute
voyez ne s'exprime pas encore bien
normalement mais chez diebolt bourges
qui parlent pas normalement
je suis là pour vous aider à faire ce
vilaine accent on ouvre la mâchoire là
comme un lopin à l'opa on va commencer
plus simple - qu'est-ce que c'est à
l'opa non payées à lèvres très bien une
pub et champion de la couleur chalon qui
va s'avérer vraiment pu au nom est en
possession que de deux voiliers lundi et
au ça va être compliqué là pour lui de
s'exprimer
ça vient de re minute belhout
quelle belle image sahara fils et de
chimères pas c'est pas le seul patient
traité mais euh c'est pas l'urgence